اعلن الديوان الاميري القطري ان امير دوله
قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني بحث مع
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني ديفيد كامرن
تطورات الاوضاع في قطاع غزه والاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله وسبل التوصل الى وقف
اطلاق نار دائم وفوري لحقن دماء الاشقاء
الفلسطينيين وقال الديوان الاميري ان
كاميرون اعرب عن شكر بريطانيا لامير دوله
قطر على جهود بلاده ومساعيها لخفض التصعيد
وانهاء الحرب في
غزه كما التقى الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن
الثاني رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري
بوزير الخارجيه البريطاني في الدوحه وقالت
الخارجيه القطريه في منشور لها على منصه
اكس ان الوزيرين بحثا تطورات الوضع في
المنطقه خصوصا في قطاع غزه واضافت ان وزير
الخارجيه القطري شدد على ان الاولويه يجب
ان تكون لانهاء الحرب في غزه ومنع توسعها